[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département et lundi 3 avril parole à
fabrice la loure le directeur du parc
france miniature le parent qui vient
tout juste de lancer sa saison et son
directeur nous présentera notamment la
grande nouveauté 2010 est une attraction
fort boyard avec la reconstitution d'une
vraie salle du conseil et la présence
virtuelle du père fouras parole aussi
dans cette émission à norbert ans paula
le nouveau président du conseil
supérieur du tennis l'yvelinois ancien
président de la ligue départementale
nous expliquera la façon dont il
envisage son nouveau rôle et les
missions du cst petit ou grand vous
connaissez forcément l'émission fort
boyard célèbre jeu télévisé où les
candidats doivent réussir des épreuves
et des énigmes dans un fort à elancourt
france miniature vous donne
l'opportunité de tester une de ces un de
ses défis excusez moi dans une nouvelle
animation elle a été inaugurée la
semaine passée plus de précision avec le
directeur du parc
nous sommes à france miniature qui lance
sa saison après sa fermeture hivernale
et l'équipe nous a préparé plusieurs
nouveautés consomme avec fabrice la
loure le directeur de france miniature
bonjour fabrice bonjour alors quelles
sont ces nouveautés qu'est ce que vous
nous avez préparé à cet hiver car la
grande nouveauté de cette saison 2010
est celle arrivée de fort boyard sur
france miniature
alors non pas le fort boyard la maquette
puisque nous l'avions déjà sur le pas
mais c'est bien la salle du conseil qui
est présenté à nos visiteurs cette année
alors justement qu'est ce qu'il y ait qu
est ce qu il a annoncé celle du conseil
on retrouve vraiment tout ce qui fait le
succès de fort boyard le fait qu'on a
envie de rendre participer à cette
émission aussi en fait exactement c'est
une immersion et on propose à nos
visiteurs et bien défier les maîtres du
fort et défier le père fouras et de
résoudre ces énigmes alors par exemple
donc là on dans la salle on a on arrive
alors ça ça ménages comment alors on est
interpellé par le père fouras qui nous
pose une question qui nous souhaite la
bienvenue mais qui nous pose très vite
des questions et après on retrouve les
grands classiques du fort le jeu de la
voilée
jeu des lumières qu'il faut essayer de
remettre dans le bon ordre fait tous les
maux grand temps fort de l'émission sur
la scène des maîtres du fort ce que là
on risque pas de se faire enfermer dans
un quelque chose c'est ça c'est moins
risqué et lancé une opération de fort
brillant justement cette fatwa cette
attraction fort boyard c'est pour les
français c'est vraiment un lieu mythique
une émission est vraiment mythique c'est
ça qui a motivé la création aussi de
cette animation
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'on a trouvé un
parallèle entre france miniature et fort
boyard les deux émissions et le parc
sont nées à la même période 1990 pour
l'émission de fort boyard 1991 pour
france miniature et on partage le même
public les téléspectateurs duo forts
sont les visiteurs de france miniature
soit avant tout des familles avec
enfants et vous constaté un manque un
vrai succès notamment sur la
reproduction aussi la maquette de fort
boyard c'est vraiment l'un des monuments
les plus importants si l'on puis dire
les monuments les plus attendus en effet
par nos visiteurs sur le parc sont la
tour eiffel puisque c'est un
incontournable et fort boyard arrive
tout de suite après parce que c'est le
shérif des enfants et poussettes une
inauguration vous avez accueilli des
invités de marque passe partout passe
muraille sont venus gentiment inauguré
avec nous cette reproduction de fort
boyard et d'après leurs premières
confidences ils sont assez bluffé la
restitution du décor c'est important
justement leur présence c'est important
et puis et leur confiance nous on fait
vraiment vraiment plaisir pour revenir
un peu plus globalement sur france
culture en quelques chiffres c'est 117
monument huit attractions 9 maintenant
peut-être c'est sain c'est la neuvième
alors le huitième c'est la huitième
alors on à 117 monument sur le parc tous
représentés au 30e de leur taille
huit attractions qui sont des animations
pour les familles mais après on n'a qu'à
15 animation sur le parc dont fort
boyard il ya des animations également
pendant les vacances peuvent devenir des
troupes de comédiens est là pour avril
vous avez des ateliers alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ces ateliers c'est vrai
que toute la saison sur france miniature
nous accueillons des ateliers pour
ponctuer la le rythme de la visite à
apporter des nouveautés à nos visiteurs
sur le mois d'avril tous les dimanches
nous aurons la ferme qui se déplacera
france miniature et partager des
expériences avec les enfants et dès le
17 avril y aura une chasse aux oeufs sur
le parc est là avec ce type d'attraction
justement l'idée c'est vraiment de
diversifier le public vous n'attendez
pas que un public francilien c'est
vraiment toute la france souvent le
monde aussi
on l'espère en tout cas mais c'est vrai
que notre public et principalement
franciliens depuis quelques années mais
c'est vrai que de plus en plus on essaye
d'aller toucher des visiteurs depuis
plus loin et c'est vrai que sur un
programme aussi fédérateur que fort
boyard je pense qu'on va aussi pouvoir
aller capter de nouveaux visiteurs
justement l'objectif de cette nouvelle
attraction c'est qu'est ce que c'est
l'objectif c'est d'apporter de la
satisfaction additionnel pour nos
visiteurs renforcer le partage
d'expériences et les émotions sur le
parc et ses vrais être capté une houle
ou aux visiteurs avec comme objectif
d'atteindre les 180 milles dieter sur la
saison 2017
après l'objectif du coup et alors un
petit rendez vous à ne pas manquer vous
l'avez cité rap non mais il ya une
chasse aux oeufs qui se serait plaint de
chasse aux oeufs une chasse aux oeufs le
17 avril prochain où tous les enfants
pourront et bien essayer de découvrir d
eau sur le parquet puis repartir
évidemment avec pour moi super merci
beaucoup
finalement donc à visiter cette nouvelle
attraction fort boyard à ce que vous
voulez revivre les aventures du célèbre
jeu télévisé dans la dans la vie réelle
voilà vous êtes attendus on poursuit à
présent cette émission en plateau avec
notre invité du jour norbert ans paula
bonsoir vous êtes depuis quelques jours
le président le nouveau président du
tout nouveau conseil supérieur du tennis
vous avez été élu début mars avec 24
voix sur 32 au préalable dans votre
carrière vous avez été pendant près de
30 ans le président de la ligue des
yvelines de tennis expliquez-nous déjà
en quoi consiste ce conseil supérieur de
tennis du tennis qui n'est pas connu du
coup puisque c'est une première quelles
sont ses missions au sein de la
fédération française de tennis
sarah entre tout à fait dans la nouvelle
gouvernance de la fédération française
de tennis
approuvé par l'assemblée générale de
2016 où il ya eu la constitution d'un
comité exécutif de 18 personnes et un
conseil supérieur du tennis auquel s'est
greffé par ailleurs ne parle des
nouveaux textes ministériels d'une haute
autorité qui est là pour l'éthique et
voir la sanction également d'accor ont
la mission du mont c'est super du tennis
est d'abord de la surveillance
l'évaluation et le contrôle de la
gestion du comité exécutif de la
fédération est par ailleurs aussi de
proposer des orientations politiques à
ce comité de
ce qui veut dire que le comité exécutif
par exemple données donnent les
directions du tennis français politique
et vous que vous êtes là un peu pour
voir si c'est ça va dans le bon sens en
gros vous êtes un organe de contrôle un
peu comme tout à fait c'est comme une
société avec ouais voilà directoire et
conseil de surveillance
pourquoi ce nouvel organe at il été créé
selon vous est ce qu'il y avait un
besoin de plus de transparence plus de
contrôle dans le tennis français est en
fait partie tout à fait dans une volonté
de d'améliorer en tous les cas soulevés
son fonctionnement
avant c'était un bureau fédéral avec un
comité de direction
les choses se décident et le comité de
direction et éviter plus je dirais une
caisse d'enregistrement que de force de
proposition alors que là on a changé
d'orientation d'autant plus d'autant
plus s'ils voulaient que globalement
cette fédération avait été quelque peu
écornée dans ce fonctionnement et qu'on
pense maintenant avec cette organisation
sa nouvelle gouvernance qui aura plus de
sagesse et plus d'action et plus de
résultats et vous en êtes du coup enfin
vous êtes le président du comité non
excusez-moi du conseil supérieur du
tennis vociférant puisque ces niveaux
vous en est le président comment vous
vous envisagez votre rôle à vous pour
l'instant vous prenez vos marques vous
découvrez vos missions alors tout à fait
on vient de démarrer
c'est le 17 mars précisément c'est le 17
mars absolument c'est donc c'est le
comment dirais-je la mise en place
progressive avec 30 de nous entendre sur
dans 24 qui sont effectivement issu de
la de l'équipe france tennis et a
remporté les élections
noah 8 autres participants céder la
seconde liste bon les choses se passent
pas trop mal pendant la première réunion
à telle enseigne que le vote s'est fait
par huit abstentions et non pas des
votes comptent en tout les cas donc
cette mission là nous la mettons
progressivement en route nous avons déjà
8 m
sur lesquels nous devrons phosphorer ces
8èmes là ça va être des groupes de
quatre ou cinq personnes qui auront pour
mission effectivement de regarder ce qui
se passe dans les différentes directions
de la fédération française de tennis et
rapporter les réflexions qu'ils pourront
avoir je dirais dans le cadre de ces
missions vous le disais justement l'une
des une des missions que l'on peut
découvrir sur le site internet de la
fédération
c'est proposer des orientations de la
politique de la fédération
est-ce que vous à titre personnel avec
les autres membres du conseil vous avez
déjà des idées du des disques vous
imaginez pour pour les mois à venir pour
les années à venir des orientations
même si j'imagine qu'elles sont pas
toutes à finir alors si vous voulez il
faut savoir que nous avons samedi
dernier tenu pour la première fois les
premiers états généraux du tennis il y
avait 16 thèmes à développer dont un des
premiers qui est vraiment le soutien aux
clubs qui sont les clubs ce sont nos
racines
le socle de la fédération et des dieux
qui font émerger aussi les futures stars
du tennis français
oui tout à fait et c'est eux qui les ont
en tous les cas par devers eux dans leur
effectif et qui nous appartient de les
faire progresser dans le tennis en tous
les cas non plus haut niveau donc ces
8èmes côté cftc se met gentiment en
place
et puis il y va y avoir la restitution
des 16 thèmes du 2 2 comment dirais-je
des états généraux du tennis ils nous
permettront aussi de travailler sur du
concret pour aider le comité exécutif en
tous les cas de faire de cette politique
que ce qui doit être la nôtre très
rapidement pour ceux qui ne sont pas
forcément initiée au tennis et à ces
problématiques quels sont les manques
aujourd'hui du tennis français qu'est ce
qu'il faut améliorer ce que ce sont les
résultats on a des très bon tennisman en
a plusieurs dans le top 20 mais jamais
de victoire
ou alors c'est pas forcément ça le
problème prioritaire selon vous
malheureusement on n'a pas assez je
dirais dans le top 20 plus il y a une
volonté de pouvoir soulever dans interne
au moins dans l'est
quatre ans qui vient dans tous les cas
peut-être le saladier on sait jamais de
la coupe davis mais ça ça va être
puisque cette semaine ci contre la
grande bretagne contre la
grande-bretagne à croire mais il est
évident ciblé que le la volonté c'est de
faire émerger en tous les cas des des
champions dans une autre forme tous les
deux par rapport à ce qui se faisait
aujourd'hui on a créé ce qu'on appelle
le podium le podium va être le
rassemblement d'anciens joueurs qui ont
gagné des tournois du grand chelem comme
noah comme j'allais vous dire un peu de
façon pis quand il y en a pas beaucoup
même non non non non il est vrai que
depuis 1932
il n'y a eu que deux arrêtés qui elle
d'ailleurs on peut noter que les filles
gagnent plus souvent que les garçons il
y avait pris une victoire en 2013 avec
excusez moi j'ai oublié son nom a pris
sa retraite récemment d'ailleurs oui
mauresmo mais par tony bartoli va
l'afrique
marion bartoli bien sûr mauresmo avait
gagné ou de l'homme mary pierce avait
gagné roland garros
donc il y avait de quoi faire
oui aujourd'hui on voit des joueuses
comme kristina mladenovic qui a gagné
deux tournois récemment ce qu'ils
trouvent en tous les cas que la force
mais il n'y a pas tellement de français
se noue parmi les vannes non plus je
voulais vous vous posez une question
pour terminer cet entretien sur votre
ancrage local vous avez été pendant 28
ans président de la ligue départementale
du tennis mais est ce que cette
expérience-là local va t elle vous
servir à un échelon qui aujourd'hui un
peu plus important ce que vous emportez
avec vous des méthodes une façon de
faire j'ai été pendant 16 ans à la
fédération française de tennis trésorier
général ce qui m'a permis aussi de
connaître un petit peu la maison et je
dirais l'expérience aussi de terrain
deux clubs puisque j'étais président au
tennis-club de plaisir en son temps mais
avant d'être à la fédération
ben may fait acquérir je dirais des des
expériences de terrain à des niveaux
différents et dans celui de la
fédération mais j'ai toujours encore
apprendre bien entendu
merci norbert rampeau la dette revenu en
plateau et puis bonne chance pour votre
président ses nouvelles fonctions c'est
la fin de ce set 8 les invités pour ce
soir prochain rendez vous demain d'ici
là retrouvez toutes nos séquences en
replay sur notre site internet tv fil 78
ou l'application tv fils excellente
soirée à tous
[Musique]